du cirill j'ai décidé de vous
réconcilier voilà michel et jean louis
oui vous allez vous réconcilier sa mère
a bien sûr cloche numérotées de 1 à 6 3
ou une tarte de dans trois n'ont rien je
vous présente et les tartes
il y à la tarte à la crème classique
mais toujours délicieux on précisé il ya
la tarte de tunis c'est une tarte
couscous et bull est périmé a été
présentée par valérie bénard 10 812 on à
la tarte alsacienne à base de chou
coûtera la halle également impropre à la
consommation
la saucisse et chez vous la merci ok
vous devez choisir chacun notre tour une
cloche celui qui tombe sur une tarte et
l'avalanche sur la tronche de l'autre à
ça c'est celui qui tombe ce rien bien
entendu les ballons sur rien n'annonce
la cloche quand même non en tout cas
vous êtes très drôle
je vous trouve très petit assis comme ça
c'est parti on y va c'est la première
manche il commence c'est parti
c'est qui le plus jeune c'est moctar qui
commence
ce rachat serait consigné j'ai
l'impression non non c'est pas vrai
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
consignés choisissent leurs cloches bas
il faut qu'il choisisse la peur pourquoi
pas même été d'abord voici ta cible
numéro 23
la 3g puis fini parce que tu peux gérer
le jeu se paie mon chéri merci l'a3
attention ne touchait pas ouvrez sk
quelque chose ou pas
sa dédicace à marquer
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je propose alors réconcilier c'est bon
c'est livrer de la nourriture est variée
à plat chez vous nous en dire voilà non
car est assise est assis on va passer
tout de suite à la deuxième manche
rappelle qu'il ya des ruptures à
l'ariane joue pas avec la nourriture
toujours juste on va jouer à passer à la
deuxième phase à la 2e manche oui on va
parier ses nombreux amis ses crêpes à
manger je compte batailler pas et là lui
vient alors je les remercie
on va passer à la deuxième manche est et
faites vous regardez vous bien face à
face s'il vous plaît
regardez vous bien dans les yeux voilà
on va amener deux classes mystère sous
l'une sous l'autre il a une clause vite
d'accord
attention d'arcade ou celui qui a la
tâche de très spécial pourra la mettre
dans le dans la tête de l'autre vous
restez assis on l'a compris principe en
main sur 3 2 a vous ouvre en même temps
alors attention ils se sont trompés
[Rires]
regardez vous d'aller sur varane et nos
tartes savoir qui va l'avoir lâché
soumis oui attention places assises
[Applaudissements]
les gars s'est réconcilié ou pas je
tuerai je vous donne un goûter attendait
que ça glisse beaucoup ne bougeait pas
au bonheur du coeur de mata le roch
maire de volta
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on peut dire ce soir jean-michel et
mokhtar serait conçu les voilà la gare
et voilà